[Music]
on this Sunday night a deepening crisis
in Canada's largest city refugees trying
to find a better life for Force to live
on the streets we're actually
compounding that trauma every minute
that we leave people out here the battle
between governments over help a new
tragedy on the front lines of Canada's
Wildfire fight as a heat Dome suffocates
a wide swath of the U.S we're also
having really high sea temperatures the
race to regulate artificial intelligence
the potential threats Solutions and
warnings about protecting Humanity
and Canadian women get ready to kick off
the World Cup I'm definitely excited the
dispute distracting from the beautiful
game
global national with paranasser good
evening to you thank you for joining us
there are millions of people around the
world right now who are thinking of
Canada with dreams of a better life but
for some refugees in Canada's biggest
city the reality has been very different
than what they expected they're here but
homeless so just steps from trendy
Toronto restaurants and shops a
makeshift sidewalk shelter has been
created and it's now ballooning in size
tonight there are calls for governments
of all levels to take action political
leaders have been caught in a stalemate
over who's responsible and who's to
blame for a situation that's being
called a crisis Amar Khan has our top
story
day by day the refugee encampment site
in Toronto's downtown continues to grow
refugees who fled persecution in a
variety of African countries to find
shelter and safety in Canada have been
without both they're already coming from
places where they're fleeing trauma and
so we're actually compounding that
trauma every minute that we leave people
out here since the beginning of June
when the city of Toronto decided to
refer refugees to Federal programs
instead of Municipal shelters saying
they were at capacity the situation has
turned more dire what started off as a
few has become dozens with nearly 50
people now on the streets they're always
there we're now just seeing them in one
particular location because they know
that they can receive some kind of
support if they're here and support has
certainly been plentiful thanks to
efforts made by Diana Chan McNally and
Community Advocates they've raised over
fifty thousand dollars and have food
water and even tents for some respite
but missing in action is a response from
the government what we need
shelter and I believe that the Canadian
government can do that and they are
capable of providing shelter for us
instead of shelters temporary or
permanent refugees have been sleeping on
the streets getting soaked by the rain
oh my goodness some saying they stay
awake throughout the night standing
still thinking about their reality
whatever since we're here sleeping on in
the rain most times whenever I drink the
rain will rain on us so it's really
terrible as for government officials
they are at odds over cost the city says
it has yet to receive more than 100
million in federal funding to cover
shelter costs for refugees but will also
need staff and shelter space but a
spokesperson for immigration Minister
Sean Fraser says that housing Asylum
Seekers is the responsibilities of
provinces and municipalities Chan
McNally says it's not uncommon for her
to see vulnerable people used as pawns
between governments we're seeing a
stalemate they don't see this as a
blight on our nation as a blade on all
of us as a country the different levels
of governments are expected to meet on
Tuesday to continue to work towards a
solution hopefully the federal
government will actually support the
city of Toronto and other municipalities
with the funding they promised but did
not commit and Marcon Global News
Toronto
one more person has died in last month's
bus crash west of Winnipeg Manitoba RCMP
confirmed a 79-year-old woman who had
been in the hospital since the Collision
died from injuries today on June 15th a
semi-struck a bus carrying seniors on
the trans-canada highway a group was on
a day trip to a casino in total 17
people died in the crash
and a gondola crash in Quebec has left
one person dead and another person in
critical condition
it happened in the resort town of
montremblanc about 90 minutes Northwest
of Montreal Quebec police say that a
piece of construction equipment hit the
gondola knocking two people riding
inside to the ground the resort canceled
the rest of a music festival That was
supposed to end today
an intense Heat Wave continues to
swelter large swaths of the United
States with temperature records forecast
to be broken from coast to coast
thank you scorching temperatures are
fueling wildfires in California
excessive heat warnings and advisories
are in place from the Pacific Northwest
all the way to Florida as Jamie Morocco
explains it's not just the land that's
getting hotter
the prescription water and lots of it as
tourists Brave Death Valley California
simmering to reach record highs for over
a hundred years we didn't hit it and
then in 2020 we got 130 in 2021 we got
130 and then we might hit it again this
weekend
four degrees Celsius is somewhat
expected when we're talking about one of
the hottest places on Earth but this
heat Dome is blanketing a large portion
of Southwestern U.S including parts of
Texas which are under a heat advisory
today here in Houston the high could
reach 44 degrees extreme temperatures
that are pounding down on California
Nevada Arizona and even Florida
in addition to having extremely high
temperatures on land we're also having
really high sea temperatures and so some
of our long-term monitoring sites here
off of Miami are starting to show signs
of early Coral bleaching and reefs
rarely recover decimating entire
ecosystems if they die it's not only in
Florida something like 40 percent of the
planet is seeing a marine Heat Wave
right now
in Canada he warnings are stretching
into the Northwest Territories and weeks
of warmth have fueled wildfires
a similar sight in Spain where thousands
have had to evacuate potentially
record-breaking extreme temperatures
have also damaged Agriculture and left
tourists scurrying for shade if it
continues to Trend now I think we're all
in for a big shock but it shouldn't come
as one
globally scientists have been sounding
the alarm for decades thank you so much
barring action this is our new normal
Jamie moroccer Global News Houston
in the Northeast U.S millions are
bracing for more intense rainfall and
flooding today tornado watches and
warnings are also in effect for much of
the region including New York and
Massachusetts flash flooding killed four
people in Pennsylvania on Saturday three
others are still unaccounted for
including a two-year-old girl and her
nine-month-old brother more than one
thousand flights in and out of the
Northeast have been canceled because of
the weather
here at home another firefighter is
being killed on the front lines of the
Wildfire fight this time in the
Northwest Territories officials say the
victim was from Fort leaird and died
while battling a nearby Blaze on
Saturday afternoon this comes two days
after 19 year old Devin Gayle died while
fighting a wildfire near Revelstoke BC
about 380 fires are burning across the
province 76 of which have prompted
evacuation orders and alerts Wildfire
smoke continues to blanket Northern and
Central BC in most of Alberta plummeting
the air quality in both provinces smoke
is also moving into the Northwest
Territories and Southwestern
Saskatchewan and as a result special air
quality statements are in effect for
much of western Canada with Environment
Canada warning the smoke could linger
for at least the next 48 hours
extreme weather is also causing chaos in
parts of Asia with at least 37 deaths
linked to flooding and landslides in
South Korea
officials say at least nine bodies were
recovered from this flooded tunnel in
the city of Cheng Yu people are said to
have been trapped in their cars after
flood water caused by days of torrential
rain poured into the underpass several
people are still missing across the
country with thousands being forced to
leave their homes due to the Heavy Rain
the South Korean military has been
called in to help with the rescue
efforts
that deal allowing Ukraine to export its
grain products through the Black Sea is
about to expire and Russia's war is
showing no signs of ending anytime soon
now Ukrainian forces have their hands on
cluster Munitions those controversial
weapons many countries including Canada
have banned Redmond Shannon looks at how
Russia's president is responding
the TQ Samson bulk carrier leaves the
Ukrainian Port of Odessa carrying
rapeseed and corn in what could be the
last grain shipment from the port under
the current Black Sea grain initiative
the deal was first brokered by turkey
and the United Nations a year ago to
safely allow the export of Ukrainian
grain products during the war
particularly to poorer countries
although almost half has been shipped to
Rich Nations the grain deal was twice
extended by Russia this year but now
expires on Monday
Turkish president
says he hopes efforts with the U.N will
convince Russia to keep the corridor
open the Kremlin says President Vladimir
Putin is waiting on a commitment to
remove sanctions against the export of
Russian foods even though Russian grain
exports have risen sharply since the
2022 invasion of Ukraine he will use
whatever is available to him whether it
is military political or economic to
extort to extort Ukraine to extort the
West
Inland on the front lines the battle's
rage as Ukraine makes slow gains in its
counter-offensive it is now
controversially received U.S cluster
Munitions banned by many countries
including Canada
in a newly released segment from an
interview with Russian State tv Putin
said Russia has plenty of its own
cluster Munitions
he claimed Russia has not used them yet
but will do so if Ukraine does their use
by both countries in the war has been
widely documented and not only have
Russians used these cluster bombs
extensively but what is called the dud
rate that is the number of these that do
not explode is extraordinarily High by
Western standards left unexploded those
can injure civilians long after a war
footage from earlier in the invasion
shows the apparent use of cluster bombs
in civilian areas at attacked by Russia
Redmond Shannon Global News London
a pioneer of artificial intelligence is
concerned over his life's work coming up
our interview with yahshua bengio on the
existential threats ahead and the need
for tighter AI regulation
artificial intelligence is taking the
World by storm and the race is on to
regulate it China unveiled new
guidelines last week and the European
Union is in the final stages of passing
its groundbreaking AI act the ACT will
classify AI systems according to four
levels of risk from minimal to
unacceptable riskier applications such
as for hiring or Tech that's targeted to
children will face tougher requirements
and in extreme cases violations could
draw fines of up to 40 million Euros or
seven percent of a company's annual
Global Revenue which could amount to
billions
[Music]
joining us now to discuss these rules is
Dr Joshua bengio a professor at the
University of Montreal and the founder
and scientific director of Mila the
Quebec AI Institute Dr bengio thanks so
much for joining us it's a real pleasure
to speak with you
my pleasure
now you were at the Forefront of
developing artificial intelligence
technology in the 80s and the 90s and
more recently you have warned about the
dangers of AI so what are your thoughts
on these new rules
well we definitely need to ramp up our
AI regulations
um over the world
including Canada and the U.S especially
because it's a
where a lot of the action is the fact
that Europe is is moving first is a good
thing it's going to push things in the
right direction and
it's it's going to be an example for
other countries
um so I'm glad this is happening
but can Europe do it alone I mean don't
AI regulations to work need to be Global
with key players as you mentioned the US
China Canada to have a real impact
I mean in democracies we should all want
to protect the public
and I understand there are also fears
from
uh industry that any kind of Regulation
is going to slow things it's going to
slow Innovation but we we have plenty of
regulations in other fields and and very
very little in the field of AI
if you eat a sandwich or you drive your
car or you you know take a plane
lots and lots of regulations exist to
protect you
um we should have this at least the kind
of comparable levels for something that
is impacting Society a lot these days
and a lot more in the future
Friends the one sentence statement you
and the top leaders in your field signed
several top leaders a couple weeks ago
with another War dire warning about the
power of AI which you alluded to I'm
going to read it for our viewers
mitigating the risk of Extinction from
AI should be a global priority alongside
other societal scale risks such as
pandemics and nuclear war and on that
note I mean 55 years ago world leaders
got together to sign that Landmark
treaty on the non-proliferation of
nuclear weapons
is that the kind of effort that this is
going to take
yes the idea is fairly simple we're
building more and more powerful tools
and and AI is probably the most powerful
something powerful could be extremely
useful and also extremely dangerous
just like nuclear energy can be very
useful and nuclear weapons could be very
dangerous
and so we need to sit down uh you know
uh the table with all the countries and
especially the ones with uh the ability
to build those tools
to agree uh on how to do it in in a way
that's going to be safe and uh and
protect the you know work for all of
humanity and and uh
we've done it in in other cases like
biological weapons and nuclear weapons
I think there's no reason why we
couldn't do it here but it's going to
take some effort and one thing that
concerns me is
the technology is moving fast so we need
to ramp up our efforts
is it the rise of machines that we're
talking about are we talking about
Terminator here what what are we what
are we seeing or what are you thinking
is going to happen no Terminator is not
not a good analogy to to consider first
of all these systems are actually
um
not very good in controlling a body like
a robot the progress in robotics is not
being nearly as fast maybe one of the
reasons is we don't have as much data
that's as kind of uh
useful to carry meaning that we have
with language
um that we don't have as big data sets
for uh building these these robotics
systems yet
but the recipe we have discovered to to
build these AI systems could eventually
be applied there
um the thing is even without a an actual
body these AI systems could could be
damaging uh humans uh could could you
know Bad actors could use them in in
catastrophic ways just like weapons have
been and and there are people who have
real concerns about
the these systems getting their own
goals and in that sense you can think of
Terminator but you know any AI of
Science Fiction typically how's their
own goal uh what I think is that we
should maybe until we know better avoid
building very very powerful and general
systems that have their own goals
Dr Joshua bengio thank you so much for
your Insight and your time and sharing
your expertise with us it's a real
pleasure to speak with you
thanks for having me
remembering the darling of French style
and Cinema ahead the world says goodbye
to Jane Birkin
a small apartment building believed to
be about 200 years old has collapsed
near Naples Italy three people were
pulled out of the rubble and taken to
hospital for fractures two passersby
received minor injuries from flying
debris but thankfully no deaths have
been reported and everyone has been
accounted for because of the collapse is
now under investigation
British actress singer and style icon
Jane Birkin who became a beloved figure
in France has died at the age of 76.
[Music]
Birkin was known for her personal and
artistic relationship with French
songwriter Serge gainsberg gaining
International Fame with their duet
je'tem one she also is the inspiration
behind hermes's famous birken bag Birkin
reportedly suffered from health issues
in recent years including a mild stroke
in 2021.
[Music]
next looking ahead to the Women's World
Cup this week could this be Canada's
year
[Music]
the Canadian women's soccer team is just
days away from embarking on what it
hopes will be a championship run of its
own the Women's World Cup is set to kick
off on Thursday with Canada among top
contenders to bring home the coveted
trophy but as Mike roulet reports the
team is going into the tournament with a
point to prove both on and off the field
it's easy to get distracted at the World
Cup there's always something to see or
do so where's the Canadian women they're
trying to focus on their first match
against Nigeria this Thursday the
reality is there's six to eight teams
probably in the world that can win this
thing and we're definitely one of those
when it comes to the actual game
Christine Sinclair who's playing in her
sixth World Cup gets a lot of attention
nobody man or woman has scored more
International goals than her many before
some of her new teammates were born and
and so listen this might come as a bit
of a shock to you but you want the World
Cup 18 year old Olivia Smith was shocked
to get the news she made the team
and no matter how good you are and see
me awujo for one is very good the first
World Cup is always special yeah I'm
definitely excited there's also like
that nervous piece just because like I'm
usually the one sitting and watching it
on TV but like now it's like I'm gonna
be the one being watched on TV so but
while the focus should be on the pitch a
third of the teams at the World Cup
still don't have payment agreements in
place with their players and that
includes Canada which has been without a
labor deal since 2021. FIFA has
guaranteed at least thirty thousand
dollars U.S for every player but critics
don't trust that that money will ever
reach them there's been a lot of
historical issues around payment of
players whether it happens at all or
whether it happens on time as far as the
Canadian team goes they're hoping at
least a short-term deal will eliminate
any distractions before their first
match you get
these four years and I can see it in
their eyes that they're grabbing this
with both hands so I hope and I know on
both parties that'll be resolved soon
and the focus can then switch from
financials to where it's supposed to be
the pitch microlight Global News
and that's global national for this
Sunday night I'm Farah Nasser on behalf
of our whole crew here I want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
Sunday evening with us tonight's year
Canada is Fisherman's Wharf in Victoria
we love seeing your Canada so please
keep emailing us your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and take care of each other good night
thank you